if you take a look at the earliest Kuna
formed tablets you will find that people
were looking for aphrodisiacs way back
when nobody's really found one all the
drug companies now want to be the first
then they're using the miracles of
modern science try to come up with
something I think if you like chocolate
and you eat chocolate you're probably
going to you know be happier when you're
having sex but no there's no way to
overpower the human brain and that's why
people have been looking four
aphrodisiacs for thousands of years
people have been looking to beat the
system somehow in in the new book that
we published intimacy and desire the
whole first part of the book is about a
fact that it's stunning because it's
true all around the world and nobody
pays attention to it and that's the idea
that the load desire partner always
control sex not because they're mean not
because they withholding it's simply
after a while the high desire partner
makes all the initiations the low desire
partner decides which one they'll accept
and that gives the low desire partner de
facto control of sex and that's why
people want aphrodisiacs they want to
beat the system they want to find a way
to make that low desire want sex when
they really don't instead of an
aphrodisiac being nice to your partner
works a lot better okay and that's tough
in marriage and dealing with things like
the low desire partner always control
sex and in half the couple's we see its
demand so the stereotype of it's the
woman who's going to be as low desire
partner and the man's going to be the
high desire partner that's simply not
the case this is not gender specific but
couples where the man is the low desire
partner that's tough for the man and the
woman because it goes against gender
roles but the whole idea of just it pays
to be nice to your partner then you
don't have to buy them candy
you are the sweet in their life you
can't just do that for Valentine's Day
or for any of the holidays or simply for
their birthday traveling doesn't help a
lot of people think oh if we go on
vacation that's going to do it and the
pressure is enormous when people go on
vacation to have sex so I my suggestion
to your colleague who was interested in
aphrodisiacs the suggestion is you're
playing with a system a lot bigger than
you that's been refined over countless
hundreds of thousands not millions of
couples and so it's worked out that you
have to learn to be able to stand on
your own two feet you have to not take
what your partner is always doing
personally you have to not overreact and
you have to go through tough times and
those are the kinds of things that
really instill long-term passion